[Applaudissements]
quelques cousins de cyril qui font du
doublage donc on va pouvoir utiliser sur
derrick notamment parce qu'on veut
garder les grandes marques comme ça
d'eric wallace a va rester sur france 3
va revenir mais ça sera pareil nouvelles
sont un petit peu ça va donner ça en a
pas et on a fait un essai cet après midi
vous nous dites si vous aimez bien voilà
regarde au boulou
ouais c'est derrick à l'appareil ma
beauté dimanche avec jean michel meyer
ya un meurtre à stuttgart faut qu'on
passe est interrogé non mais attendez je
suis même pas prêt - nam étudier ou pas
il dit qu'il n'est pas prêt cet [ __ ]
il va m'entendre je te jure on arrive
chéri d'eric arrive fait des boulettes
ses noces et derrick
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est nous aider chez nous aussi des
jeux presque envie de le voir parce que
vous aimez le cenou cd rom et ses tours
remettait toujours des trous étaient
tous ces partis arles osé aller
[Musique]
le bouchon ouais c'est délicat
l'appareil ma beauté dimanche avec
jean-michel mais rien ne recrache tous
deux gardent faut qu'on passe est
interrogé non mais attendez je suis même
pas prêt - non mais tu le vis ou pas il
dit qu'il n'est pas prêt cet [ __ ] va
m'entendre je te jure on arrive chez ni
des ricains vivent vieux des boulettes
c'est nous c'est derrick
[Musique]